it has begun what's going on guys this
is Rob and and we are we are officially
on the road to the age of apocalypse we
are BAM we are we're heading down this
road I never actually thought that you
guys we're just going to be like yeah
Age of Apocalypse America I've never
actually thought you guys are gonna be
you know that that excited about it so
I'm really excited that you're excited
that being said here's what we're gonna
do so what we're gonna do I'm doing um
there's two things in this video that I
want to talk about first one is just to
rehash just to make sure you guys are
aware we'll probably be into the summer
of 2015 before we're like into Age of
Apocalypse part 1 now what does that
mean what it means is that the whole big
summer event like that whole thing that
Marvel is doing is gonna have to be put
on hold and once we finish age of
apocalypse we'll get into that now
that's not a big deal I mean will will
be it'll it might be the spray more so
than the summer but it means that like
by the time that event comes to a close
then we'll be able to start doing
explanations and and you know making the
whole summer event makes sense so I
think it's all going to like time itself
out really really well so so don't worry
you know I'm not gonna blow off the
whole Secret Wars 2015 summer event
thing I mean we'll definitely get into
that but the other half of this is a lot
of you guys that have been around since
the beginning or a lot of you guys that
went back and watch my old videos you
guys know that we talked about like the
x-men we talked about cables stuff like
that but the problem with those videos
is that they're they're antiquated in my
mind like I didn't really like the cable
video that much I didn't really like the
x-men video that much and the reason why
is because those videos are not up to my
current standard on how I do and marvel
explained videos of course it makes
sense I was starting out the process was
evolving and it's even evolving now it's
growing and it's changing now but what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go back
and we're gonna rework or I guess you
know redo all those videos so like we're
gonna go back and I guess like remaster
the x-men video so it's not going to be
eight minutes it's going to be longer
than that
and we're gonna talk about you know like
the whole x-men thing the difference
here is a lot of these videos we're
gonna be explaining them up until the
age of apocalypse to degree with the
x-men we're gonna explain beyond with
cable we're gonna explain beyond you
know beyond Age of Apocalypse but with
some characters like the nasty boys for
example they were big in the 1990s an
x-factor but aside from that they
weren't really that important you know
Madeline Pryor we're gonna be explaining
her but only insofar that we're talking
about Jean Grey Jean Grey were gonna
explain up until the age of apocalypse
and the reason why is because most all
the stories involved her were really big
because of like 1980s Chris Claremont
the Phoenix and the Dark Phoenix saga
which of course we're gonna get into
when we explain Jean Grey but one thing
I wanted to ask you guys is is there
anybody that I haven't talked about yet
that you want me to I'm sure there are
and so you know characters like mr.
sinister for example we're definitely
gonna have to talk about x-men we're
definitely going to talk about will
probably explain x-man after Age of
Apocalypse though because Nate grey like
x-men was introduced during Age of
Apocalypse he wasn't before the Age of
Apocalypse so we won't have to do him
after depends on what you guys want to
see but if there's any characters that
were part of the Age of Apocalypse
that's like that you want to have seen
they you want me to discuss that you
want to make sure get into our
discussion videos then post them in the
comments section now I know they're
probably gonna be repeats of various
characters and that's fine people are
gonna be like you know you know explain
storm there's gonna be like 50 people
who say explain storm that's okay it's
not a problem
just you know I'll comb through the
comments because again I want to make
sure I get these videos out I'm gonna
comb through the comments and and I want
to make sure I get those characters done
while I'm doing that I'm also going to
be explaining characters like right now
I'm making sure that I have all my
information right on mr. sinister you
know I want to make sure I have my
information right on ganden stuff like
that so you know characters like
juggernaut you know we're gonna go back
and revamp those characters any of the
old characters that you had seen that
we're part of the x-men universe that
had like a still picture where the
videos were like eight minutes or
something like that we're gonna be
revamping those so the videos are going
to be more
deaf they're gonna be more intriguing
and they're gonna be longer so I just
want to make sure you guys know what so
let's want to give you guys heads up
that we're basically gonna be like
remastering all the old videos and there
is anybody you guys want to see so if
you guys want to see like I don't know
like Nightcrawler like post Nightcrawler
in the comments section and and I'll
definitely make sure that Nightcrawler
gets done so anyway this this is your
chance to make your voice heard to say
Rob make sure this happens make sure
this gets done so that it'll it'll
actually happen as opposed to when a lot
of you guys post comments and stuff I'm
like okay like like I'll try to see if I
can do that but I can't guarantee it if
it's if it's a character in the comment
of this video a video will be done on
that character so as long as it's not
one of the Avengers and as long as he's
part of agent apocalypse anyway I'll
catch you guys later peace